un polinomio p tiene cero cuando x es
igual a menos 4 x es igual a 3 y x es
igual a un octavo cuál podría ser la
ecuación para p bueno vamos el vídeo y
piénsalo antes de que lo trabajemos
juntos
ok el hecho de que tengamos ceros en
esos valores significa que cuando x es
igual a algunos de esos valores
pd x es igual a cero es decir
pd menos 4 es igual a 0 pd3 es igual a
cero y p de un octavo es igual a cero
antes de ver estas opciones podemos
pensar cómo construir un polinomio que
cumpla esto esto será cierto si podemos
expresar un polinomio como el producto
de expresiones donde cada uno de estos
valores de x haga esas expresiones igual
a cero así que cuál será la expresión
que resulta en 0 cuando x es igual a
menos 4 bueno la expresión x + 4 es
igual a cero cuando x es igual a menos 4
así que me gusta
cuál será la expresión que resulta en
cero cuando x es igual a 3 bueno
será la expresión x menos 3 si x es
igual a 3 entonces esto será cero y cero
por lo que sea es igual a cero por lo
que puede 30 en este caso ahora cuál es
la expresión que es igual a cero cuando
x es igual a un octavo bueno será x
menos un octavo y bueno estas no son las
únicas expresiones ya que puedes
multiplicar las por constantes y aún así
los principios que acabo de mencionar
serían verdaderos pero buscamos un
polinomio que se vea como este puedes
intentarlo si x es igual a menos 4
entonces esta primera expresión va a ser
cero y cero por lo que sea por lo que
sea es igual a cero lo mismo para x
igual a tres si x es igual a 3
entonces x menos 3 es igual a cero y
cero por algo por algo es igual a cero
por último si x es igual a 1
entonces esta expresión es igual a cero
y cero por algo por algo es igual a cero
así que cuál de estas opciones se parece
a esto veamos x + 4 aparece en las
opciones de idea
la opción se tiene x menos 4 aquí lo
cual evalúa en cero cuando x es igual a
4 si x es igual a 4 esta primera
expresión sería igual a 0 pero a
nosotros nos interesa que eso pase
cuando x sea igual a menos 4 así que
cancelar este inciso y por la misma
razón cancelar el inciso a entonces la
respuesta está entre b idea y después
veamos cuál de los dos tiene x menos 3
en el bueno podemos ver que x menos 3
está arriba de abajo es decir está en
ambos por lo que la respuesta sigue
entre b y d pondré otra marca indicando
que ambas siguen correctas hasta este
punto y por último pero no menos
importante cuál de estos dos evalúa a 0
cuando x es igual a un octavo bueno
veamos si hago un octavo por un octavo
me dará 1 entre 64 un 64 ambos para eso
parte de la expresión y eso no es igual
a 0 ya que las otras dos expresiones no
serán cero cuando x es igual a un octavo
así que este inciso no se ve correcto
pero veamos el otro si x es igual a un
octavo tengo 8 x un octavo lo cual es
uno menos uno eso me dará cero así que
esta funciona y seleccionaré el inciso t
como respuesta y tal vez estés pensando
oye este polinomio se ve un poco
distinto que este polinomio que escribí
arriba cuando intentamos obtener un
polinomio para el cual se cumpliera esto
y como he mencionado puedes multiplicar
estas expresiones por constantes y se
seguirá cumpliendo lo mismo al
multiplicar este último factor por 8 no
cambias los ceros y si distribuye este 8
esta última expresión te quedará como 8
x menos 1 que es exactamente lo que
tenemos aquí